you know many people care about how
their Instagram layout looks when
somebody lands on it when only 1% of
people do that in the beginning to begin
with who are all gonna cry that they
didn't put out more content during this
golden era you got your perspective
[Music]
because you actually have a business
success like a real one a real tangible
one for that matter you I think you
really need to use that as your shield
to experiment here's what I mean by that
if you play it out from even for me and
I'm like pretty far along in this like
all of it comes down to the lack of
content Tom comes down to judgment and
insecurities it really does write like
even I at where I'm at like think about
like okay somebody's gonna go and see
how good is my engagement to my four
point one you know because I think all
of us go on that random Instagram
account that has eight million followers
and you see they have 3,000 likes and
like no comments and you're like oh this
person bought them what a loser did it
it it it up so what would I would I
would I think what really helped me
period
is like no matter what anybody says like
I you lost your way on Twitter you're
not as good at this then I always have
like but in the macro I've built actual
businesses right like I've had a
business success I think one way I'm
just trying to give you like a thing
that might work for you like who cares
if a piece of sawdust gets posted on
Instagram and it flops and like somebody
comes and sees that I got seven hundred
likes instead of like five thousand
which is what you should get for that
many followers like you need to find a
trigger in your head to perfectionism or
I want it to be good it's just not true
it's a it's a it's a facade and makeup
for insecurity and vulnerabilities and
so you need to figure out what trigger
gets you okay with giving the team more
autonomy to put you on third and a half
base it's really this very meta
I just said the dirac before this drive
that we're taking in wine country
working on this wine project
hey man when we get a huge mistake we
have all this great video content and I
if I really think back to what made me
good at Wine Library and kind of makes
me good at social is weirdly even though
I have no grammar skills though they've
gotten a little bit better over the last
ten years I'm a really good copywriter
like I know what to say that will get
people to pay attention to it and I go I
feel the reason that a lot of the
content that I'm being given right now
I'm not posting I've come to realize
it's not the video it's the way you guys
titled the meme right so so I said - I
was like look start sending me the raw
videos I'll reply with the titles and I
have a funny feeling I'll be posting
more and even as I'm telling you this I
can feel the chemicals in my body saying
that's exactly right
I think you need to let your team put
you on third and a half base right like
give you the clip or whatever the
sawdust is and like you know like I said
the John who's Trouty right now who's
driving I was I have to go send an email
to ask somebody to make a cameo in this
wine promotion video and I don't want to
do it because I hate asking it's
unbelievable how much I hate asking
people to do anything ever any time and
forever
I hate it but but having a Chris Rock
cameo or whatever the [ __ ] and this will
really help and so I have to do it and I
literally said to him I'm taking a
flight tomorrow from San Francisco pound
me like bug me until I do it I think you
need to give permission to your team of
like like I think d-roc and I work well
together because I really through the
last three four years it was like look
even if I snap and I'm like [ __ ] you
like you know like leave me alone I'm
dealing with a fire at Vayner or like
that's not important like that's not
true and just keep pushing me because
that's what I need you have to create a
framework and trust with your team of
like when you're not giving them the
copy or physically posting it or
whatever system that you've created that
you're the bottleneck that they have the
ability and the triggers to push you
through until it becomes second nature
it's just so important posting here's
the only thing that's not debate like
quality of a video of the creative
that's debatable people debate if it's
good if that was funny if that was
thoughtful if that was a good post
quantities not debatable
post the days not debatable and it is an
absolute requirement and here's the
biggest thing brother and I'm saying
this for myself too
you and I were to be really [ __ ] sad
when instagrams algorithm collapses the
way Facebook's did and it can happen any
day and then we're all gonna look at
each other and be like [ __ ] when
I had the chance to post four times a
day and get 30 40 50 percent organic and
now I only get 2% I'm a [ __ ] idiot
so that's it man you know like I really
I highly recommend you look you're gonna
get all these cost savings I'm taking
this internal I would pour that into
internal capes overwritten an audio and
video and just go you know just really
push yourself create that breakfast
thing or you know the framework reach
out cold to the a-list of the a-list you
know obviously have a lot of friends so
you'll have a lot of people who can
actually do it for you too you know
this guy knows that guy this gal knows
that guy this guy knows that gal I guess
the biggest thing I'm saying and again
I'm really reinforces selling myself you
got to squeeze when that moment exists
and I think that has been driving me so
much in the last two years that this is
such a special time that will go away
and then while we're waiting for voice
apps or augmented reality or whatever
the [ __ ] we're all gonna think back to
these you know glory days of you know
2014 to 2018 as times where you could
have really built and we didn't take
advantage of it just like email open
rates at ninety percent just like
Facebook feed just like unlimited
consumption on Twitter dude when I had
7,000 followers on Twitter all of them
saw everything every time you're not
gonna care about being precious when you
can't get distribution
right now everybody's being fancy do you
know many people care about how their
Instagram layout looks when somebody
lands on it when only 1% of people do
that in the beginning to begin with who
are all gonna cry that they didn't put
out more content during this golden era
so that's kind of where my energy is on
that
[Music]
[Music]